just moved out here for an internship
i'm 22.
still not quite sure what my end goal is
i get asked what's your five-year goal i
want to figure out not by me clearly yes
maybe
she's about 70 more years i guess my
question is if you were in where knowing
what you know now what would you say to
your 22 year old self because i've been
throwing some darts trying to see which
one sticks but i'd just love to hear
from you
my if i gave you the actual answer it's
so complicated because at 22 the only
thing i wanted to do was build my
family's business for them
and i was kind of like the talks i was
having were weird which is like you're
gonna give up the best years of your
life for your parents because they did
it for you and like i had like this
altruistic like noble like family
immigrant vision and i was psychotic
about it like literally did not like
like actively tell people like i went to
everything is best in balance like it
would have been okay if i went to the
jersey shore once in my 20s
it would have been okay but i didn't
that's how psychotic i was i think but
the reason i'm so happy is because i'm
gonna give you the answer of what ties
that together which is
the only thing you should be thinking
about is if everything was perfect
like as if i was a genie from the future
and can grant your actual wish you have
to try to make that actually happen
meaning even if you've never said to
your dad only to yourself not even your
best friend like if you've said to your
own self
that i want to be an actress or i want
to be a doctor or i want to
be a supreme court justice or an
entrepreneur whatever that is whatever
it actually is
that's what 22 to 30 is about
it's all high risk it's the biggest
[ __ ] falsity that has been sold to
kids now you've got to actually know
what the [ __ ] you're doing
as if
you're actually in the best position
ever to execute
something that's not practical you don't
need a lot of money to live you can live
with 40 of your [ __ ] friends let
alone three you could
you can eat like [ __ ] in your 20s so you
can buy dollar food and like you can
just you don't have kids you don't have
you don't oops sorry uh you know you are
you are in the most practical place from
22 to 30 to do crazy ass [ __ ] but the
world has taught kids that that's the
time you're supposed to have it figured
out it's insane
so my advice to you is
whatever your biggest single dreams are
that you've kept to yourself have been
scared to even think you could you've
got to challenge yourself to try and
that looks like this
whatever i just said if it is supreme
court justice it's interning it's paying
a law firm even though you didn't go to
law school to like be an assistant like
people understand how life actually
works like if you could just get into
the game weird things happen
right if it is hollywood life like you
need to move to la and like [ __ ] like
work for like it's working for free
which comes in all shapes and sizes your
dad is a successful business person you
might be able to afford to work free and
that's okay that's like family dynamics
work for free is also working at safe
ryan reynolds worked at safeway that's
working for free that's nine bucks an
hour like you know that's the that's the
theory right like it's zero if you're
miraculously in that situation most
people aren't some are it's okay my kids
will be for example it's okay or minimum
wage but in the thing
or
a shitty job that gives you plenty of
hours to be in the thing i tell a lot of
people who want to be influencers to get
like a job at 7-eleven and just make
content all day while they're standing
behind the register
like you know like get a job that's not
actually making you do anything so that
you have time to do the thing that's
true
i mean
i don't want to think what people are
doing right now that i'm paying them you
know like
you know like so you have to go for your
actual dream the one that scares you the
most because it's the one you want the
most but you haven't even thought you
had a chance to do it that makes sense
it's it actually makes sense this is
what why i'm so passionate about it
if not now when
but but the world really [ __ ]
everybody up like this concept that you
have to now you went to college and you
thus now know what the [ __ ] you want to
do who sho of course certain ironically
orthodontic doctor yes of course there
are a small group of professions that
the passion in the school and you know
for everybody else
nobody's doing the [ __ ] thing what
and that's where everybody is and and
you guys have know your options you have
so many options because of technology
but the real answer to your question is
the dream that you haven't even
felt comfortable believing in
i love that
thank you you're welcome